das corona virus breitet sich weiter aus
frankreich meldet den zweiten todesfall
zahlreiche neue infektionen gibt es in
china und in südkorea
auch in deutschland gibt es neue corona
fälle in nordrhein westfalen und baden
württemberg sind fünf menschen positiv
getestet ein mann befindet sich demnach
in einem kritischen zustand und liegt
isoliert auf der intensivstation in
düsseldorf dem 47-jährigen bereits vor
erkrankten mann aus erkelenz der wie
seine frau auf der intensivstation in
der düsseldorfer uni klinik liegt soll
es etwas bessergehen er muss aber immer
noch beatmet werden
der mann arbeitet freiberuflich seine
frau in einem kindergarten in einer
pressekonferenz informierte der
krisenstab des gesundheitsministers
heute nachmittag die medien
das ehepaar hatte zahlreiche soziale
kontakte und hatte auch eine
karnevalsveranstaltung besucht das
ehepaar hat dann auch noch einen
kurzurlaub in den niederlanden gemacht
so dass wir dann auch die niederländer
natürlich darüber informiert haben das
hotel und so weiter was da alles
notwendig ist
deswegen gibt es zahlreiche personen
kontakte im kreis heinsberg dann hatte
das paar auch die uniklinik in köln
besucht hier konnten 41 personen
identifiziert werden
die nun auf das virus getestet werden
müssen in göppingen hatte sich ein
25-jähriger frühzeitig selbst gemeldet
der sich auf einer italienreise
infiziert hatte aus seinem umfeld sind
zwei weitere personen in tübingen
erkrankt der zustand der drei patienten
sei so der dortige krisenstab aber
stabil
verdachtsfälle gibt es zudem in moers
leverkusen und köln waren
wir wissen dass 80 prozent der infektion
relativ milde verlaufen so dass man
jetzt nicht unbedingt an eine cola
virusinfektion denkt es kann schon gut
sein dass wir jetzt eine stille
ausbreitung des virus bereits haben und
dass wir jetzt in den nächsten tagen
vereinzelt fälle hoch kommen werden und
es wird sehr schwer sein hier eine
eindämmung zu erreichen
in heinsberg bleibt male schulen und
kindergärten vorsorglich bis montag
geschlossen
ein unternehmen aus hilden hat heute
einen schnelltest vorgestellt der eine
mögliche infektion mit corona viren
innerhalb einer stunde beweisen kann